so we're going to talk about some
dough's here of one of which but before
we do it I should show them how a
mathematician thinks about elasticity
yes anyone made bread you should all go
home and make bread but so if you make
bread so there's this molecule in wheat
which is gluten actually it's two
molecules it's gluten and glutenin and
gliadin and basically these are proteins
that basically unform cross with each
other they stick to each other to form a
gel and then what happens is when you
need them they tend to line up the
molecules and the molecules whether
they're very long and they like to stick
to each other by short-range interaction
volute and that basically gives bread
dough's or strength anyway so if any of
you have AIDS what you learn is if you
want to make the dough stronger then you
either add salt or you use high-protein
flour and which gives it more gluten and
there are also ways of making a weaker
you can add fats or oils sugar or add
acidity and I think mark and our friends
at Johnson & Wales have made for us
three types of dough right mark yeah
courtesy of the the baking department at
Johnson & Wales we have this one this is
made they're all the same recipe one is
made for cup with a cup for cup which is
a gluten-free flour also developed by a
graduate of Johnson Wales this is a
high-protein bread flour which is around
13% protein and then this is vital wheat
gluten which is used often in the
processed food industry it's 75 percent
gluten this is not why people have
allegedly have celiac disease which is
an immune deficiency disease but perhaps
gluten intolerance could potentially
stem from this stuff but we're going to
roll oh you just stuff is amazing we
were saying this before you you guys all
have to make this and go home and
players yeah
Wow now imagine that in your lower
intestine huh yeah but now let's try the
bread flout the normal bread bar this is
actually not like regular regular high
low key no you guys didn't even use
those made over that over 92 so that's
pretty go check it out that's cool
oh you echo goes right again oh that's
pretty cool okay now this is the most
amazing thing this is deep do it
gluten free flour and by all appearances
it looks the same you see doesn't it
look like flour allowed to develop its
developer night overnight even longer
than the regular flour okay okay so
shall we do it okay ready ready you guys
have to watch this fast ready one two
it's like it's like ricotta cheese I
mean this is how it's like how do you
make anything from this you may pop out
of this yeah what was I thinking how do
I but yeah I mean it's a challenge as
you can as you can imagine I mean gluten
is really amazing it's it's magic it's
magic and the amount of ingredients
necessary in this dough to poorly
simulate make sure you might be turning
out what's in the gluten-free flour so
actually mark gave me the ingredients in
this gluten free pop flour for you all
to admire so it has cornstarch which
doesn't have gluten it has white rice
flour brown rice flour no gluten milk
powder tapioca flour no gluten
potato starch no gluten but then at the
end there's this ingredient
it's a white powder made this lovely
sauce over here it's a white powder that
was used in a lovely sauce it's called
xanthan gum and xanthan gum as you saw
in the sauce sort of crappy yeah it does
bind things together a bit but that's
basically the only thing in there that
binds things together and that's that's
decidedly the best version of a
gluten-free flour really available on
the market right and you can pair that
with this stuff and it's just
unbelievable I mean this stuff basically
has the property that like air doesn't
I don't know if you've ever baked bread
is what makes Wonder Bread so delicious
right here this is us they put this in
Wonder Bread yeah well because they
don't want it like I don't want to take
the time to allow it to you know for men
and rise naturally so you put that like
idea yeah that's easy yeah science